- Welcome everyone to the daily home room.
I hope you all had a good weekend.
I know, or as good as
weekend you could have
given given the circumstances.
For those of y'all who are
new to our daily homeroom,
this is really a way
for us to stay connected
as we go through this
whole crisis together.
Especially the secondary
crisis, I guess you could say,
given how many students in
the US and around the world
are currently out of school.
As we started to see that a
lot of the closures happening,
all of us at Khan Academy
as a not for profit
with a mission of providing
a free world class education
for anyone anywhere realized that one,
the resources that we have
already been working on
for many, many years could be
really valuable for teachers,
students and parents as they're
navigating these closures.
But we also realize that
it's our duty to do more,
to really step up so that you
feel as supported as possible.
And so starting with about
two or three weeks ago,
we started releasing daily schedules
and everything I'm talking
about it's all available
at khanacademy.org.
If you go to the, the
page, you'll see banners
and you'll see a modal show up
and you can go to the
various resource pages.
But we have things like daily schedules
for different age groups
that a lot of people
have found useful, that can walk through
how a student can structure their day,
not just in math but also
in reading and writing,
the sciences and the
humanities by grade level.
How can they can leverage
things like Khan Academy,
kids for the early learners.
We are also on these resources
or on our various web pages
putting out webinars
that parents and students
and teachers can attend.
You can look at the
latest on the resources
if you go to Khan Academy.
But just so you know,
we're going to be having
several webinars over the next few days.
April 1st, second and third,
we're gonna have a webinar
on, the first one will be for
young kids, age two to seven.
This is really for parents
to think about how to
set up a daily schedule.
Then the next one will be
for elementary students,
ages two to 10 and then
for middle school students,
11 through 13.
And similarly we're gonna
have teacher webinars
on those days for elementary students,
middle school students
and high school students.
So we wanna do whatever
we can to support you.
Part of the fun of this daily homeroom
is that we wanna make it
as interactive as possible.
Please over whatever you're
using to stream this,
whether it's YouTube or Facebook.
But we're also monitoring social media
on Instagram and Twitter.
Ask us questions, this
is where we're gonna try
to answer them and we're also gonna try
to bring in special guests
over the next few days
and weeks to help answer more
and more of our questions.
And so, with that I will
bring on Dan, my colleague,
who will help us go through
the various questions
and I'll also make one other announcement.
I do this everyday.
I do remind everyone, Khan Academy,
we are not for profit organization,
we are funded by philanthropic donations.
We were already running at
a deficit before the crisis.
And through this crisis, our
server usage is about 2.5
I wouldn't normally is and
obviously we're trying to do
more programs and more services.
So if you are in a position to do so,
please consider donating.
I do wanna give special thanks
to everyone who's donated
over the last several days
actually, it just turns out
that somebody posted one of our videos,
highlighting our need on Reddit yesterday
or over the weekend and that
resulted in a lot of donations.
Thank you.
I wanna thank various corporate partners
who've stepped up in really record time.
Bank of America was the first,
followed closely by 18 T
google.org and Novartis,
all of that makes a huge difference,
but I also wanna remind
everyone, we still need more.
We're still running at
an accelerated deficit
and so we wanna be able to
support you as much as possible.
So with that, Dan, let's
answer some questions
and please ask us
anything on these various,
whatever you're watching this on.
- So sign up today.
We're gonna try to do Instagram.
We're not streaming live on Instagram,
but we'll, we'll try
to get there this week.
From Instagram, Gregory Hin asks.
What is the main thing that drives you
to continue making videos
free for all students?
- Oh, well, you know, I think maybe,
maybe it's somewhat obvious,
but I'll answer the question anyway.
And to be clear, Khan
Academy is much, much more
than me now, we're over
200 full time folks.
There's thousands of
volunteers around the world,
who make Khan Academy the work.
And I think I'm speaking for everyone,
including the many thousands,
actually tens of thousands
of hundreds of thousands of people
who've donated to Khan Academy.
Many of you, I think the,
the, the need to society
of a world where anyone on the planet
is able to tap into
their potential, I think.
It's, it's huge.
If you look at almost any
other problem in society,
whether you're talking
about obviously healthcare
is a topic these days,
but if you're talking
about economics, if you talk about safety,
if you really keep peeling
the onion on one way
or the other, it does
boil down to education.
And if you look at, you
know, access to education
and quality of education and
what people's living conditions
are in the world, there's
definitely a strong correlation
and they obviously feed into each other.
So I personally, I can't
imagine, I consider myself
the luckiest person on the
planet that I get to devote
as many as, as much of
my energies as possible
to this problem or to the
solution of empowering folks.
I think it's just a very,
very powerful multiplier.
You know, as famous that
you can give people fish,
but you can also teach them to fish
and that's what education is really doing.
So that's what drives me day in, day out.
There is another, I would say
a layer, a selfish motivation,
if you will, which is I
love the creation aspect
and I love, you know, all of
these topics that we cover
on Khan Academy are
really beautiful topics.
And oftentimes I think,
students feel like, Oh, I gotta
go through this and you know,
when am I gonna use this?
But I think there's a,
there's a joy that we hope
we can bring to students
and teachers and parents,
to realize that this is inherently
beautiful subject matter.
And it's fun to dive in deep with it.
So, anyway, I'm incredibly
inspired day in day out
to be able to serve all of y'all.
And I think everyone, I speak for everyone
on our Khan Academy team, all
of the thousands of volunteers
and the many people who've
donated like, like yourselves.
- So, so another one from Instagram.
This one, Moogy asks, how is Khan Academy
planning to help AP students
study for online AP exams?
Actually where we're working
on getting college board
to join you on this homeroom
and some folks internally as well.
- Yeah, no, that's a
very relevant question.
For those of you who don't
know, you know, the AP,
which are these advanced placement tests
in the United States and
some parts of the rest
of the world, these are
essentially advanced high school
or intro college level
classes that are taken
at the high school level.
And at the end of the
year you traditionally
have something called an AP exam.
And depending how a student
scores from one to five,
they could get various
levels of college credit
depending on where they,
where they go to college.
And this year, testing
globally has become difficult
because it's not clear that
school will be in session
during the test, AP tests
are normally in April,
timeframe late April or early May.
And, obviously, other forms of tests
are also a lot of question marks.
So the college board has announced
that they're going to do an
online version of the AP,
which is going to be
different from previous years.
And what we are doing
is we are coordinating,
we're, we're close friends
with the college board.
That's another not-for-profit.
They're the folks who administer
the SAT and the AP exams.
Khan Academy has always had
the official practice partner
around the SAT, but we also
have a lot of AP content
around calculus, statistics,
biology, chemistry, physics,
microeconomics and
macroeconomics, American history,
AP CS principles and civics in government
or American politics.
So, what we're going to
do is continue to try
to improve the resources that we have.
And as we get closer to the AP exam,
we're gonna think about
partnering with college board
to provide other ways so few people
feel as prepared as possible.
What my recommendation to
any student who is preparing,
especially if it's a subject
that we have the resources for,
is try to get as close
to 90 or 100% mastery
on Khan Academy in that AP
subject, in that AP course.
And when I say mastery,
you have as much practice
as you need on Khan Academy and you'll,
there's these mastery mechanics
that will keep leveling you up.
You can leverage course challenges
to just understand how well
you know the whole course
at this point you can use
unit tests to break it down
by unit and then you can keep leveling up
with the, with the various mechanics.
And then as you get closer to the AP test,
what I recommend is we do
have worked example videos
of the free response and the
best way to consume those
is start at the video, look at
the prompt and then pause it.
And I usually do say pause the video
or one of our content
creators say pause a video,
try to answer it yourself
and then let the video play.
So you get that practice.
And I think if you do those two things,
you're going to be quite prepared.
And we're gonna work
with the college board
to get more information
out because I know this,
this version of the AP is going
to be a little bit different
than what we've seen in the past.
So see other questions we have.
So from Facebook I see Shala Kareema says,
my fifth grade son is a smart student,
but he doesn't challenge himself at all.
He thinks he knows everything.
How can I help him?
You know, I'm not an expert here
and I hope in future live
streams we can bring in some,
you know, child psychologists or coaches
or, or whatever else.
My gut sense is, you know,
this all is about growth
mindset versus fixed mindset.
And there is some research showing
how to help coach people to a,
towards a, a growth mindset.
Based on your description,
it sounds like your son
might be falling into a fixed mindset.
Now he thinks, his fixed
mindset is, I'm very capable.
I know this stuff.
But even if you're a fixed
mindset is one of confidence
that might actually keep you from engaging
in things that you find difficult,
which it sounds like
might be happening here.
Because if you already
have a self perception
that you're very protective
of, that I'm capable,
then you might be afraid to
test that self perception.
And so what I would do
is work with your son
as much as possible to
build a growth mindset.
Remind your son it's not about
some innate ability level.
It's how much you're
willing to push yourself
out of your comfort zone and
your brain grows the most
when you push yourself
out of that comfort zone,
you struggle even fail but
you reflect on that failure
and pick yourself back
up and history the world.
However you wanna define happiness,
people who are able to, or success,
people who have a growth mindset,
who are always pushing themselves,
who don't say I'm smart or dumb,
but say, Hey, I just need to
understand what I'm capable of
by keep pushing myself I embrace failure.
They're going to be
disproportionately successful
regardless of what your
definition of success actually is.
So other questions from
YouTube, Adhithia asks,
what is your favorite book
that changed the way you think?
So Adhithia there's many, many books
that have changed the way I think,
but relative to what
we've been talking about
at the Khan Academy mission,
I think one of them,
is, is actually the foundation
series by Isaac Asimov,
that's more than one book
but if I were to pick one,
I would say just foundation.
And actually I'm gonna give,
I'm gonna give two books.
One is the foundation series.
The foundation series I first
read it in middle school
and what I found inspiring
about it was, you know,
it's a story, it takes place 30,
I'm not giving away any of the plot line.
It takes away, it takes place
30,000 years in the future.
Humanity has colonized the galaxy.
There's a galactic empire
and there's this professor
named Harry Seldon who sees
that and he, he, he, he studies
a combination, it's a
new field of mathematics,
statistics, economics, history.
And he's able to statistically predict
large scale historical movements.
And he sees with his mathematics that the,
there's a large probability
that the galactic empire
is about to enter into dark ages,
the dark ages that will last 10,000 years.
And so he decides to
do something about it.
He wants, and you know, in the dark ages,
the empire will get fragmented.
Knowledge will be lost, you'll
have war, you'll have famine.
And so he statistically
sees that if he's able
to preserve the knowledge of humanity
in the periphery of the galaxy someplace,
he, his math shows him
that he will be able
to shorten that dark ages from
10,000 years to 1000 years.
And, and that's what the foundation is.
It's the preservation of knowledge.
And when I read that, when
I was in middle school,
there was a, there was a few
takeaways I got from that.
It was a bit of an aha that if you really
want to preserve the essence
of what makes a civilization
capable, it really is
knowledge and education.
And, and if you really
wanna help society the most,
there's a lot of other
things that matter as well.
But knowledge and education
are at the root of it.
The other thing that I
found really inspiring,
it was this notion, obviously
it's a science fiction book,
but this notion of thinking
far beyond your direct life,
your direct degeneration or
then your or your direct benefit
that as human beings we
sometimes need to think
on a larger scale and
on a longer timescale.
And obviously Harry Seldon in the book
is thinking on a thousands
of years timescale.
And so when Khan Academy started becoming,
I guess you could say a thing,
I started tutoring family
members and one thing
led to another and many of
you all started using it.
You know, there was a
world where Khan Academy
could have just become an
interesting YouTube channel.
There is a world where
we could have just become
a software company in a tech company.
But there's a world where we would think
about it a little bit
more like Harry Seldon.
And this was delusional for a guy
operating out of a walk in
closet not too long ago,
10 years ago?
But what if it could be a
foundation for the world?
What if it could be an
institution for the world
that can help billions of people
tap into their potential for generations.
And so, that has directly
impacted my hopes,
my aspirations for what Khan
Academy can be and should be.
And you know, this type
of crisis pinpoints it
cause we're going through
a global crisis right now.
There's 1.4 billion
students around the world
who normally would be in
school but are now not
and, this thing we're creating,
Khan Academy has a role to play.
So we're already starting
to hopefully help out a bit.
And then you could imagine
in 50 years, 100 years,
well beyond, you know, my lifespan,
I hope that in 100 years, 200 years,
people would have trouble imagining
what the world was like before
everyone had free access
to things like this that I
hope they take it for granted
that anyone, regardless
of where you grew up,
you're going to be able to have a lifeline
and tap into your potential
and have access to opportunity.
So there's other questions here.
So one from Instagram, someone
says, how do you earn money?
This is a Arife.ercon on Instagram.
And so the simple answer
is, and I've talked
about it at different live streams.
Khan Academy is a not
for profit organization,
which means no one owns Khan Academy.
I don't own it or you own
as much of it as I do.
It's a public charity.
But all of us who work at Khan
Academy, we do get salaries
and then that, those salaries
come from the donation.
So when folks donate to Khan Academy,
some of it goes to our server costs,
which are even before the crisis,
were running at around
six or 7 million a year.
Our traffic is about 2.5 times that.
So we could see, you know,
10 $15 million a year
of server costs or more.
And then a lot of our budget
is paying the salaries
of the engineers, the
designers, the product managers,
the content creators, the
folks working with classrooms
and districts, the folks
running the webinar
to pay all of their
salaries so that we can
create this platform that
you know, now we're seeing,
you know, tens, many tens
of millions of students,
you know, tens of millions
were using it before.
And, now it's, it's, it's
increasing dramatically.
So other subjects, other
questions and Dan filler
I'm just picking, you
know, randomly from this.
So actually I like this
question on Facebook.
Agam Mathia asks, how
can I help my community
during these times?
You know, I was talking to my
wife about it and you know,
even my mom, you know, I'm,
I'm, I'm kind of worried
about her she's by herself in New Orleans.
And obviously she's,
she's of a higher risk age
and, you know, frankly, just
the loneliness of, you know,
not just living alone, but
now being socially distanced,
but then she has to worry
about how she gonna get
her groceries and things like that.
And so I think one potential idea,
especially for you younger
folk who have a lower risk,
and, but even then you should
take extreme precaution
is, you know, find
especially senior citizens
in your community who
might need help getting
the groceries or things like that.
And, doing it for them you
know, just as a service,
and, you know, still
take all the precautions,
make sure you have, you
know, try to wear a mask,
whatever you can do to, to
minimize your own exposure.
But, if, if your family has the means,
you can buy the groceries and
just leave it on their porch.
Or if the senior has the means,
but it's just highly
risky for them to go out.
You know, for some find
some way that they can
provide the funds, but then
you can go do the grocery.
So it's a very tactical,
very simple thing.
But I think it's very powerful.
I think there's another
layer, which is make sure
that the people in your
community feel connected
in this time of social distance.
Obviously people are
worried about the virus,
but the next worry is people are feeling
very lonely right now.
And so I think, especially
with a lot of these seniors,
but I would say anyone in your community
make sure everyone feels
somewhat connected.
So that might be a getting on
a video conference with them,
just talking to them about life.
There's ways that we can
connect with each other
and support each other where
we don't have to be in person.
Yeah, so those are, those
are two of my ideas.
There's other ideas, you know,
I know in a lot of places
the blood banks are
running low because of it.
So if you're young and you're,
you can do it in a safe way.
That's an interesting thing.
So there's, I'm sure many,
many other opportunities
to, to volunteer.
- So we have a question
from the curious student
from YouTube, I believe
you're the best teacher,
but who do you think is or has been
the best teacher to the world?
- Well, thank you for that kind of remark.
It makes me, I think, you
know, there's, I will never
make a superlative comment
in almost any domain,
especially something like teaching.
I think there's different
types of teaching
and there's, and different
people are going to resonate
with different folks.
You know, I like to believe and thank you
for your compliment that
the things that I create
or the things that our team
here at Khan Academy creates
resonate with as many people as possible,
that help motivate them, help them learn.
But you know, the work that
teachers do day in, day out,
goes far beyond that you
know, that's the work
of you know, working
with individual students,
individual classrooms, making
sure they're motivated,
you know, diagnosing an individual student
that, okay, it might be this academic gap
or there may be, there's something at home
that I can help them with.
And so the really amazing teachers I know
are the ones that really
form those connections.
And you know, when I think
about my own childhood
or education, I had many,
many amazing teachers.
I was very blessed that way.
I grew up in Louisiana and the,
but you know, many teachers
almost every year, I
can name at least one,
but, you know, in high
school I had teachers like
Ms. Kennedy and Mr. Hernandez,
and they were incredible
teachers of their subject area.
But what I really remember
is they, they were,
they were very connected
to all of us students
in a very open way.
They, they treated us, you know, they,
they put constraints on
us as they should have,
but they also they, they,
they treated us like peers.
I remember Ms. Kennedy
was our journalism mentor
and so, that modeled a lot of, you know,
what I try emulate now in Khan Academy,
that Khan Academy should never
feel like we're the teacher.
You're the student.
It's really that, you know,
we're just two human beings
trying to help each other.
And maybe right now we have
a little bit more knowledge
and, you might be the recipient of it,
but it is a little bit
more of a equal thing
you know, Mr. Hernandez
was my, algebra two teacher
and then he was the mentor for
several clubs that I was in.
If I go back to middle
school, I remember miss North,
you know, she used to run
her and I remember Ms. Ellis
in fifth grade, they
both used to run their,
their English classes, like,
like university seminars.
And I remember that was really fascinating
and it informs a lot of
what we now recommend,
for what the best model is
when, when folks get together.
Yes, use Khan Academy if you
need lectures at your own pace,
use Khan Academy to get
a practice and feedback
and to get some of your foundations.
And then ideally that
can free up class time
to run it the way that
Ms. Kennedy or miss North
or Ms. Ellis ran their classes,
which is more dialogue,
more simulations, more games that really
push that higher order thinking.
So anyway, there's a lot of
layers to what makes something
a great teacher and a lot of
different types of teachers.
But, but thank you for the compliment.
So there's one question that
I'm actually intrigued by.
No one's ever asked this before.
This is from Agam again,
asking Khan Academy
should provide resources
for college essays.
So we don't have the resources
for college essays yet
or, or we don't even
have plans for that yet.
We do have some resources
on college admissions.
If you do college admissions Khan Academy,
do a Google search, you'll find it.
But my advice for folks
writing college essays
is just be authentic, just be yourself.
I think sometimes folks get
so stressed about things
that they try to optimize it
so it's perfect in some way,
but when you try to
optimize, it's perfect.
You're not letting your true self out.
You're not letting your vulnerability out.
And you know, I've talked
to many of our advisors
are actually heads of
admissions departments
at some you know fairly
selective universities.
And they tell me, you know, you can't,
how many kids just kind
of fit a certain pattern
and they're just trying to
have this perfect essay.
But the ones that really appeal to them
are the ones where when they read it,
they're like, Oh, I see the student,
I see the person behind this.
This person is quirky,
this person's authentic,
this person's honest.
And those are the folks, once again,
and they have a growth mindset too.
They're not trying to make
their life look perfect.
They're willing to admit their failures
and they're owning their failures.
Those are the students that they like
to bring to their community.
Those are the students that they think
are going to be able to do
amazing things in the future.
So that's my, my best advice
is just be as authentic
as possible in your essays,
introspect who you are,
don't try to be, you know, some ideal
that you think other
people want you to be.
And frankly, that's life
not just for, that's advice
not just for college essays
but probably for life.
- So we have a question on
Facebook from Scott Yang Sao,
and this is on the mind
of lots of students,
Sal, will students have
to restart their courses
because of the school closures?
- So I think that is, it's
a very fluid situation.
What we've seen in various districts.
I would be, I would be
shocked if you have to restart
your courses, like if you were
taking high school biology
this year, then all of a sudden
you're gonna have to retake
high school biology next year.
I don't think anyone is,
you know, in the districts
that we've been talking to
suggesting that type of thing.
I think what will happen,
I know some of our,
the local districts
out here in California,
they've kind of moved to a
bit of a pass fail system.
So at least you get credit.
I think what we're
going to have going into
the end of this school
year over the summer
and the early next school
year is I think teachers,
schools, districts are
going to be very open
and colleges are going
to be, college admissions
are going to be open
to alternative evidence
that you mastered the subject.
I don't know what these
are fully going to be.
I do, you know, think that
if you are able to master
something on Khan Academy and
print it out and you know,
sign a, you know, promise,
you know, so that,
that it's your work on an honor code
and it should really be your work,
that, that even that might carry weight
cause people are looking
for alternative measures
in this next year and I think
everyone is trying to earn
on the side of doing right by everyone
versus trying to be punitive.
But I think that it's a two way street.
Everyone, you know, you're the student.
It's on you to be you
know authentic and honest
and of your true state and not try to game
whatever system gets put in
place over the next few months.
But I, I wouldn't feel anxious
about having to completely repeat it.
I think there's ways that you can show
that you have that knowledge,
and that if you're,
if you're good at
marketing it so to speak,
you will be able to, to do fine.
And you know, when I go
back, think of even my own
high school experience,
obviously I didn't go through
what we're all going through right now,
but there is a certain
power to self-advocacy.
So I remember I wanted to
take some advanced courses
at the university of New
Orleans when I was 15 or 16.
And I remember walking in there,
you know, 14 or 15 year old
and they're like, who are you?
I'm like, I'm the high school kid,
I go to, you know, Grace King High School.
It's about four miles away.
I'd love to take, you know,
multivariable calculus.
And they're like, we
don't offer that to you,
but I'm like, no, I'm ready.
And they're like, well, how
do we know you're ready?
And then I had to self advocate.
I'm like, give me a test, here's this.
And I obviously didn't have
Khan Academy back then.
And I think if you advocate
for yourself, you'll also,
people will, will appreciate that.
So I think that's another
way to think about it.
So we have more questions
here is so from Instagram,
this is a question we've
gotten several times.
What's the best way to
avoid procrastination
and, I don't wanna pretend that I'm immune
to procrastination,
I've done my fair share
and I think especially
in the context we're in,
where the news is, it
kind of sucks you in.
It's very easy to convince you,
Oh, let me just spend five minutes
looking at what's going on in the world.
And then that can turn into
a longer than five minutes.
What I try to do is actually one thing,
and I try to limit how much I
look at the news these days.
I wanna be informed, but I
don't wanna be sucked into it.
I think the other thing is,
and this is during this crisis
or pre this crisis, just
always have a, some structure
and have a bit of a checklist
and then you can build that
momentum during the day.
I've talked to multiple live streams.
I like to wake my bed
first in the morning.
I like to do a meditation
first thing in the morning.
I always get ready first
thing in the morning,
even if I have nowhere to
go, even if it's a weekend,
I try to do a little bit
of exercise and that those
early wins helped me build
momentum into the day.
And once I get into the office
or in and now the new world,
when I just start working from home,
I try to, okay, what are some things
that I can, I can get some wins on.
The other thing, and this
is the Pomodoro technique
that we've talked about
which is try to give yourself
some windows to work and then
make sure you take breaks
as well so you don't get burned out.
And what Philippe is showing you,
is we've actually made some meditations
to help you stop procrastinating.
And these are meditations
just to kind of a way
to be reflective of your own thoughts.
But you know, the gist
of the, the meditation,
the procrastination one is, you know,
don't let your brain convince you.
Cause it's oftentimes the
fixed mindset in your brain
that is afraid to get started.
It's afraid to get started
because it might discover
that it's harder than you thought
or you might not finish it in time.
And that somewhat self destructively
that fear keeps you from starting
and it becomes a self fulfilling prophecy.
It does become harder though the key
is at that thought process and say, no,
I don't care what you're
trying to convince me brain,
thoughts, I am just gonna start.
I am just going to put one
foot in front of the other
start and see what happens.
And if you do that, then it kind of breaks
that procrastination
circuit in your brain.
And then as soon as you
start, most times you're like,
Oh, this isn't so bad,
this is kind of fun.
Whoa, why did I procrastinate so much?
But that's, that's you
know, there's other games
you can play with yourself
or if you have a due date on something,
just, you know, tell yourself
of the due dates earlier.
We, we could, we could talk about that,
but I'd love any ideas y'all have as well.
It's not like anyone has
solved procrastination.
But we have ways of dealing
with it or, or minimizing it.
Let's see, there's a
bunch of questions here.
We have some from Facebook.
I'm not Chima says, what do
you think about new programs
in the near future that could impact
a few next few generations?
Well, I, it's a fun
question to think about,
you know, in the
education realm, obviously
I hope Khan Academy is in a position
that we can help billions of
folks for generations to come.
And there's things that
I hope we can layer on.
I hope one day Khan
Academy, you know, someone's
the question about credit
or having to repeat classes
allude to something
that I hope Khan Academy
can play a role in, in the
future, which is help people
connect the learning on Khan Academy
so that they get opportunity in the world
or they get credits.
So, you know, there's a
lot things that we could do
on the Khan Academy layer.
I think the other really
interesting things
that are going on in the,
in the world right now,
obviously we're in the midst
of a healthcare crisis.
But I think in healthcare
you're going to have,
you know, there's CRISPR technology
where we're gonna be able to
start literally editing DNA.
There's some scary aspects to that.
We were in the position
to edit our genome,
but there's, there could
be some very positive,
powerful things from that as well.
I'm inspired by some of the
things that might be happening
in, in, in, in communications.
Obviously the fact that we can
do this type of communication
right now without a ton of planning.
You know, in this time
of crisis can you know,
it's making the whole
world a lot more connected.
I'm inspired by some of the things
that might be happening in energy.
You know, we're all worried
about what might happen
in the climate and whatnot.
But, there's, there are
some silver linings.
There's, you know, people
working on nuclear power plants
that might not have any,
nuclear waste to them
or radioactive waste to them.
Solutions like that I
think are pretty inspiring.
I'm also inspired by, you know,
new models of transportation.
People are talking
about ways to, you know,
flying cars and whatever
else and they, they actually
seem more real than not
obviously, space travel,
reusable rockets, satellite
networks that can give everyone
broadband and connectivity
like we have around the globe.
I think all of these
are gonna be incredibly
transformational and they all
in fact affect each other.
And you know, they actually
all would have impact
on what Khan Academy is as well.
So let's see, there's
other questions here.
So some from YouTube,
Susanna Dominguez asks,
what is your favorite
part of Khan Academy?
Well, you know, that's like
asking who's my favorite child?
I don't have (laughs) a favorite.
I will say what I think
is the most powerful part
of Khan Academy you know a lot of people
associate Khan Academy with videos
and we are proud of our videos
and videos are an important
part of what we do.
But I would say the most
powerful part of Khan Academy
is the practice and
assessment exercise platform
that we have where students
can get functionally
unlimited practice, immediate feedback.
There's mechanics for them to
progress at their own pace.
And then all of that
ideally works when teachers
are able to look at
their teacher dashboards
or parents are able to
look at either the parent
or the teacher dashboard
to help unstick students
and then to open up what
can happen in class time
to be a more higher, higher order.
So I think that's my, that's what I think
is the real power of Khan Academy.
The, the, the, it's nice to
get these micro explanations
if you're stuck, but the
real learning happens
when you try exercises,
you, you get feedback,
especially when you get it wrong.
And then you reflect, you look
at the step-by-step solution
and the hints and you're like,
Oh, and then you keep trying.
And then you see it in
a context wishing mode
on a unit test or, or something like that.
So, we are out of time.
Y'all asked, you got
me on me on my soap box
on some of my, I should say
from my favorite questions
of like where could these
be in thousands of years.
But, but thank you everyone for joining.
I know this is an incredibly
hard time for the world.
I would say just as one human
being to another human being,
the silver lining of
that is that we're all
in this together, this
is a shared experience.
I remind myself that and
whenever I'm feeling a little,
isolated and socially
distanced, and I remind myself
that I'm in a much more
fortunate situation than many,
many folks in the world
are, are finding themselves.
So we're all in this together
and I think we're gonna
get through this together,
and, you know, take care of yourself,
stay healthy, stay safe.
And all of us here at Khan
Academy are going to do
whatever we can to support you
and please in future live
streams, come on, give us tips,
feedback, ideas for how
we can do that better.
Thank you.